this thomas qui est prête à accueillir
comme enfin la récolte dès cet après
midi
six ans après s'être lancé dans la
production de fraises en serre jouets
lalancette peut se targuer d'être le
premier au québec a récolté le petit
fruit rouge en plein hiver une fraise
qui a néanmoins un goût d'été une phrase
qui chronique qui est rouge foncé qui a
une très bonne conservation qui crée une
prime en prime son entreprise la
frissonnante est en pleine expansion
trop à l'étroit dans ses serres de
drummondville elle a emménagé dans les
anciennes installations de savoura aden
ville à la fin de l'année dernière
dessert pratiquement cinq fois plus
grande
vingt-huit mille mètres carrés de plants
de fraises à perte de vue notre
superficie tradition aussi ses
supérieurs à tout ce qui se fait en
amérique a réuni ensemble faction c'est
un produit final c'est le produit qui
est prêt à livrer ces petits emballages
sont vendus 5 ou 6 dollars environ deux
fois plus cher que les fraises de la
californie et du mexique qu'on importe
en hiver par contre un produit de
qualité
je me plains comparer un peu nos fraises
ou bien des microbrasseries un petit
luxe qu'un nombre grandissant de
consommateurs est prêt à s'offrir les
fraises de la frissonnante sont
distribuées dans une centaine de
supermarchés métro principalement dans
le grand montréal et la chaîne
d'alimentation souhaiterait en recevoir
davantage et ça va très vite ya une
réelle demande c'est un produit vraiment
différent reconnaît pour y avoir goûté
pour comprendre et lui elle est juteuse
vu l'engouement pour son produit
l'entreprise ne parvient pas à répondre
à la demande ses clients dont certains
grands restaurateurs montréalais vont
s'arracher les 300 tonnes de fraises
quelconque produire cette année on
produit pas assez présents pour honorer
toutes les commandes qu'on a quand même
si c'est un créneau prometteur moins de
dix producteurs cultivent des fraises en
serre au québec et seul le frissonnante
est en activité pendant les mois les
plus froids de l'hiver la facture
énergétique élevé qui fait grimper les
coûts de production n'est pas étrangère
à la situation
c'est la première année qu'on utilise
l'éclairage artificiel l'occupant d'un
tarif préférentiel jouets lalancette
bénéficient d'un tarif préférentiel
d'hydro-québec pour l'éclairage de sa
soeur ce qui réduit de moitié ses
factures d'électricité
si on parle de coup d'éclairage à 50 à
60 mille dollars par mois si on arrive à
tarif préférentiel on sait acer 10 100
1000 par mois qui fait une énorme
différence le sol et les revenus nets au
bout de la mecque
mais ce tarif n'est offert qu'aux plus
grands producteurs ceux qui consomment
au moins 400 kilowatts heure pour une
période de facturation pour l'instant le
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention
d'abaisser les tarifs d'électricité pour
les producteurs en serre qu'il estime
comparables à ceux offerts en ontario et
en colombie-britannique plus qu on
encouragerait les petits plus cliquer
sur le tram afin d'amener du groupe 65
compétition ce serait bon pour le marché
ici olivier bachand radio canada dan
ville